that was my back up uh sorry Paul an uh
but you're very good uh you know this
the White House is in trouble when it
comes down to kamla to save them the
vice president trying to reassure the
world that her 81-year-old boss Joe
Biden has what it takes to be leader of
the Free World for four more years
despite mouny concerns over his
age there a lot of people would say she
can't say anything else she she couldn't
tell if there was a problem I'm not
lying I'm telling but but I'm telling
you a fact there ever is a problem yeah
do you think that you could go tell the
American
public do you think in your role that
you're that you're in a position to do
that of course if necessary but there's
no need for
that well that's reassuring do you think
just about an hour later President Biden
stepping all over kamla's comments by
cracking this joke which is doesn't seem
to be very funny about the nuclear
footfall now look my my Marine carries
that has a code to blow up the world
that do this is not nuclear weapons is
it all right
okay and while Joe Biden jokes about
Armageddon K is also not proving herself
to be ready to step into the job at
presidency the vep having some serious
trouble answering a simple
question what should happen to Tik Tock
well I'll step back for a moment and say
that one of the things that should keep
all of us up at night is the level of
Miss and disinformation you you don't
have a specific VI on on Tik Tok itself
I'm not commenting on that are you on
Tik Tok yourself I not do you are you
not like a people in my family are I'll
tell you that and you tell them to get
off you know you can tell young people
in your family all kinds of things to
do so Dana that wasn't a yes or no what
would have been the right answer on that
well I think it's hard to want to be the
leader of the Free World and have no
comment on something as consequential as
Tik Tok I do think that her uh what she
said at the end about trying to tell
young people that that was relatable yes
relatable and I thought that that was
very good she's always going to be asked
is Joe Biden too old she needs a better
answer she needs to have something along
the lines of ignore the haters he's on
top of it and move on and drive on to
something else one of the things that
she said was about the this was the
question about his age and she says it
is important we not be seduced into one
of the only arguments that that side of
the aisle has right now on this issue in
a way that isn't tended to distract from
the accomplishments I don't there's
there's nothing that you can land on on
that and so I thought she I mean it was
fine for her I don't know if that
answers the mail for their serious
polling deficit that they have right now
um she'll be out
there campaigning on uh voting rights as
well as um misinformation you heard it
there and also they're going to try to
make this election a choice between
Biden and whoever the Republican nominee
is and if it is Trump the whole thing
that that's going to come down to is do
you want stability with a guy that yes
we know he's 81 do you want stability or
do you want chaos and that's going to be
the choice that they try to make have
Americans make rather than saying do you
want another four years of the Joe Biden
kamla haris presidency so uh so what you
get Katie just reminded me when she just
broke into misinformation they told her
right before she goes on stage make
these points so regardless of they fra
to tell her you also should listen to
the question and see if it's appropriate
they didn't probably finish the briefing
but if you ask VI ramaswami or Senator
Rubio senator Ruby goes ban Tik toac VI
says you can't that's how you get the
young people those are two candidates
those people ran for president you know
exactly where they stood is there a harm
in saying in making a decision there is
well first the question about whether
she would tell the American people if
something were wrong uh the American
people can watch and see the president
and his decline which is why Democrats
are worried about his age they can see
for themselves they don't need the vice
president to tell them what is or what
is not happening with him if there were
to be something wrong on the Tik Tock
issue they clearly believe this is a
national security threat because it is
banned on federal government devices a
number of Governors have banned it from
government devices across the country so
they acknowledge it's a threat but they
are not willing to acknowledge that
threat when it comes to the political
side that Tick Tock affords them because
they are using it for young people and
not only using it but working with
influencers on a number of different
projects that they're trying to push out
whether it's on Healthcare or inflation
they watch it very closely to see what
the young people are talking about and
they're worried about not getting those
voters so they're willing to use it as a
political tool despite it being a
national security problem um while they
at the same time acknowledge that it
should be banned for federal government
employees so uh Jesse one thing she did
walk they Ed the Ron Clan quote saying
that she's getting a hard time ratings
are low because she's a woman and she's
a woman of color and she says yes
because the media uh in fact I have the
sound that says very similar to what I
said watch Von Cay says this U and and
and you've you've seen press about
yourself over over the years he says
that he believes that your popularity or
uh unpopularity or whatever rating you
want to put it as is a function of
sexism and racism he says that's part of
the problem he says she doesn't get the
credit for all that she's done do you
think that's
true well are we talking about the media
or people as it relates to the media I'm
sure some of that is
true well it's true I don't get the
credit I deserve because I'm a straight
white male and it's bothered me for my
entire life
Brian I can't believe you the credit you
deserve I I'm still a rising star right
I understand do you remember when she
was asked by the media if the
president's brain dead you promise
she'll tell
us or are you going to keep it a secret
and she goes no I'll tell you if he's
brand dead think about that I mean this
is crazy we're having this conversation
that's a decacus moment and then the Tik
Tock thing I'll answer it and I'm not
even a politici you say my
Administration is engaged in very
delicate and consequential negotiations
with the Chinese these involve a lot of
National Security issues when it comes
to cyber security election security uh I
don't want to get ahead of the president
on this issue but we'll have more for
you in the next
month instead she says no like instead
she's like I plead the fifth no comment
it's so stupid Brian right and she also
answered the qu was asked the question
about her like checking boxes you were
picked because you're a woman woman of
color and that's something that still
lingers he goes he said she said I don't
understand the question Harold this is
directed to you please pay attention I'm
still writing down that I thought that
was an incredible response that you laid
out for her to be able to give about how
the administration that was very good
you know I really should run maybe this
is the ticket so Ford Waters so the Dana
Dana LED this right I don't understand
how when the vice president is in these
incredibly important settings and Andrew
sorin is a serious journalist and I
thought had a great conference yesterday
you had to anticipate some of these
questions including what are you doing
how do you think about the president's
ability to stand how do you not say
unemployment is down in inflation
inflation's coming down gas prices are
down investment in America is up we
building chips that go in refrigerators
and cars and laptops we're finding ways
to build prescription drugs in America
so we're not relying anywhere else in
the world but here more Americans have
health insurance and women know that
they have a right to an abortion if Joe
Biden's in office that's what we are but
but Dana these are the things to your
say I mean I know it's not that hard but
Dana
you I don't know how know but the pre
you laid out the predicate for this is
what they should be saying two she smart
and she's talented but she does not have
a lot to show for as we stand here now
almost three years after they've been or
more than three years is after they've
been in office I don't understand why
you don't go to the Border I don't
understand why you don't why she was one
of the great attorney generals the
country has seen in California how you
don't get on this crime issue and she
was criticized because they thought she
was too tough on crime somewhere how you
don't get on the crime issue we' talked
about it you talked about Dallas having
a great police chief and a mayor now I
think the mayor you've had him on your
show switch parties uh Democrat the
Republicans he wanted to fight crime in
a different way talk about that as one
of the great best practices in the
country and talk about how we can take
that National and finally on that issue
of Tik Tock and said to after saying
Jesse's point so you know I'm the mother
and I'm a father of a young daughter but
I'm the mother of of of young women
we've got to figure out what's happening
with these algorithms introducing and
perhaps trying to habituate women to
young women to bad habits and bad
practices that's going to be my next
task Andrew I'm going to take up and
we're going to get on this before the
election and put forth proposals for the
country that you want this is not hard
but it is can I add one more thing yes I
just want to just answer the problem is
being tough on crime is not good for
Democrats they don't want to hear it I'm
a Democrat I disagree with you no but
they don't want to say it he's tough on
crime they're going to go back to if
they would say it they would do better
and their poll numbers would go up
because people say that's our second
number one second number one second
concerning issue um but I also wanted to
mention this she was asked do you think
Israel is following the rules of war
that is our closest Ally here's another
reason why they're going to have
problems she says well there are many
rules of War there's only one answer to
that question and the answer is yes and
President Biden supports the Israelis
and in their mission to destroy Hamas
and she didn't say it right I also think
it would be great for Democrats to crack
down on the border but they don't want
to talk about the Border they don't want
to talk about crime because for some
Democrats do I wish they could I wish
they would be better for the country I
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else